[Musique]
où
tous les animaux que j'ai vu aujourd'hui
et hier sont des animaux qui sont
en relativement bonne santé avec
clairement des lésions qui sont
compatibles avec des captures dans le
filet oui
[Musique]
chaque année en fait on bat le record de
l'année d'avant donc
après l'assaut sont pas des jarrets des
caractéristiques qui nous plaisent
d'atteindre des records absolus pour le
statut de l'espèce et au maintien de la
biodiversité dans l'île
à la suite de le top 6 à laquelle j'ai
assisté ce matin je suis à la fois
bouleversé scandalisé bouleversé parce
que on parle très peu finalement de la
souffrance de ces animaux or il ne meurt
pas à noyer il meurt asphyxié et ça peut
durer plus d'une demi-heure d'agonie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il faut suspendre les pêches
dans les zones sensibles pendant au
moins un mois certains aux commandes
davantage pour en finir avec cette
hécatombe
[Musique]